bonjour à toutes et à tous la délégation
vient d'adopter les conclusions du
rapport sur la politique du logement
outre-mer sujet dans notre délégation a
décidé de se saisir lors de sa réunion
de programmation pour la présente
session parlementaire se tient tout
d'abord évidemment à vous en rappelez
l'économie générale puis je cèderai la
parole à notre excellent à porter
victorin lurel qui je l'espère pour nous
parler de puissants territoire 10 mois
depuis son isolement en l'occurrence
fois plus précis micheline jacques puis
président guillaume gontard mais enfin
nous livrerons à la séance rituel des
questions réponses avec les journalistes
qui sont présents ou en distance yale
pour cette dernière partie je vous
propose de garder votre caméra allumés
afin de me faire part de vos demandes de
prise de parole via le tchat
donc on vérifiera également ses demandes
de prise de parole en faisant simplement
un signe puisque nous sommes à la faune
présentiel et on visioconférence et je
demanderai à chacun de bien vouloir se
présenter au préalable avant de formuler
sa question ski facile quand même les
changes
le choix d'une étude sur la politique du
logement dans les outre-mers s'est
imposé à nous ont raison de la gravité
et non pleurs de la situation en
septembre 2020 la cour des comptes a en
effet rendu public un rapport
établissant le quasi échec du plomb
logement outre-mer 2015 2019 qu'on
appelle le club 1 est rappelons-le est à
repenser ces dispositifs d'intervention
pour les recentrer sur la réalité des
situations locales
cette thématique a donc été omniprésente
lors de l'examen du budget d outre-mer
pour 2021
j'ajoute que nous faisons tous le
constat dans nos territoires d'une
aggravation des difficultés de nos
concitoyens pour se loger
il s'agit d'un phénomène extrêmement
préoccupant pour aujourd'hui et pour
l'avenir
le choix de cette étude exprime aussi
notre inquiétude car le nouveau plan
2019 2022 diplôme 2 a pris du retard et
l'an prochain alors du bilan nous
risquons de nous retrouver à nouveau
avec des objectifs non tenues et un
constat identique voire pire celui d'une
inadaptation des outils de la politique
du logement aux besoins des territoires
ultramarins dans leur diversité
nous avons donc voulu faire oeuvre utile
en proposant dès à présent une autre
approche qui prennent bien sûr
quand la mobilisation des acteurs du
logement qui a nous ne nions pas
l'existence d'un grand nombre de projets
mais surtout qui corrige les failles
méthodologiques et déficiences actuelles
je voudrais saluer ici le remarquable
travail de nos trois rapporteurs qui ont
eu la délicate mission de conduire de
nombreuses auditions pour l'essentiel en
visioconférence en couvrant à trois
bassins océaniques avec les problèmes de
décalage horaire et de connexion que
cela suppose pour appréhender la grande
complexité de cette politique et la
diversité des situations de nos
territoires
trois rapporteurs en mener un travail
d'investigation approfondie pendant six
mois a ainsi donné lieu à une vingtaine
d'auditions dont cette table ronde soit
plus d'une centaine de personnes
auditionnées
au cours de plus de 40 heures d'audition
pour le présent rapport comme à
l'accoutumée les comptes rendus des
auditions seront annexés aux rapports
d'information est consultable sur le
site du sénat leur transcription
représente plus de 350 pages d'onex le
rapport de la délégation a l'ambition de
reconstruire autour de 70 cette
proposition soit autant que le plomb 2
une politique du logement qui soit tout
simplement plus efficace les supports
qui vous ont été distribués la note de
synthèse du rapport et la liste des
recommandations vous permettront de
suivre promo démons les présentations de
nos rapporteur laure cède la parole sans
plus tarder en premier lieu à victorin
lurel pour la première partie de l'étude
qui est consacrée notamment au cadre
général et au financement puis je
passerai la parole la machine jacques
pour les différents volets de cette
nouvelle politique qui vise à permettre
une offre de logements adaptés aux
besoins réels des territoires et enfin
ce sera le tour du président guillaume
contart pour la dernière partie plus
prospective de l'étude cher victorin
vous avez donc la parole
comme tout
leur donc le micro voilà je téléphone si
c'est pas ton numéro avec le droid ce
problème de réseau ici plus sereine à ce
problème
ok en tout cas l'on vous entends très
clairement vous invite dans sa parole
quelle est la question alors c'est la
présentation de votre parti aux
journalistes en l'occurrence lyon m'a
dit bon je dirais que pourquoi avoir
fait ce rapport donc on va voir quelle
était la nécessité
depuis plusieurs années les rapports
sans pile une loi uniquement ça tu lui
contant en tant qu'élu de tirer au
constatons que l'objectif de
construction de dix mille logements
neufs par an n'a pas été atteint que des
milliers de nos concitoyens ou hst débat
à se loger
cette europe 1 on constatera également
que les boules magiques de l'habitat
dignité les personnes est ici un billet
en cause nous constatons également que
la vita sociale continue de se dégrader
que les centre-villes dp vis et que
l'ascenseur du parcours résidentiel
c'est pour elle que ce sont arrivés avec
tout ce que cela implique en termes de
ghettoïser chiens de protection des
populations on constate aussi que la
crise de la représentation des filles et
des actions de loge entre mer dans
l'hexagone notamment celles entre lieux
somme a été aussi une année de forte si
ces éléments sont globalement par ghazi
et qui par les acteurs de terrain qui
par les autorités publiques
notre fonction commandait le conduit une
étude indépendante aurait un coût rouge
et en profondeur
l'efficacité à la politique de l'eau
noire dans les eaux de ce travail qui
aura nécessité plus de 43 heures de
soleil sur l'a7 puis de travail et
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont
contribué à ce rapport
je salue tableau de labatut ressort de
ce travail moi je sors donc on a bâti
financière et budgétaire sur la cloison
de
reste alors le constat que je résoudrai
ainsi l'assèchement continue aidera si
ce n'est pas public en faveur du
logement de mère est allée de pair avec
le développement clinique et
communicationnel autour de nationaux et
candy man salvateur
en d'autres termes moins ça faisait plus
riche qu'on prétendait le contraire
deuxièmement les chiffres parlent d'eux
mêmes le premier est en continuelle
évolution
traduction concrète d'un désengagement
massif des pouvoirs publics
l'ecri 10h en autorisations d'engagement
de l'alb il ajouté en loi de finances
cet avis est à environ 270 millions
d'euros sur 2010 2014 puis autour de 247
présidence une 2015 2017 pour attendre
que 100 millions d'euros en 2018 et 2019
au total depuis 2000 blouses réel des
jeux a diminué de près de 5 500 pour nos
grandes collections de la guadeloupe
les montants dyer exécuté sans passer de
60 millions d'euros en 2010 contre -
rennes 5 millions d'euros en 2020 près
de 135 millions on est à 126 accession à
la propriété trapped dirigeants des
rangers cette amélioration du parc
locatif cap millions 2 on est là c'est
l'acteur jean amélioration du comprimé
34000 dans 9 38 ans ni à 22 millions
l'accompagnement des petites figurines
et d'aménagement et notamment le brassus
32 millions et 23,2 millions car il
chante 237 millions et 1,7 alors qu'en
2012 le volume global de construction et
de réhabilitation s'établissait ainsi
quatorze 1138 les deux sont passés à
8500 46 en 2018
7300 cap en 2019 et illumine cent en
2020 une légère donc remonter le chenal
seconde opération d'accession sociale à
la propriété est lui aussi en très forte
baisse à saint etienne ou bien de serait
171 ans d'une ans à seulement 5 9
opérations contre les rebelles à 2009
avec une rupture profonde de sinatra de
l'état à compter de 2018 alors votre
approche qui est notre mission
fondamentale consiste ainsi à dépasser
les postulants trop souvent asséné par
les pouvoirs publics pour déceler les
véritables causes de cet échec patent de
la politique du logement outre-mer
après analyse des données écoute des
acteurs un véritable acharnement a
obtenu des réponses et éléments
tangibles auprès des services de l'état
ce rapport dresse 4 conclusion première
chose parce qu'ils valent d'effondrement
des crédits la halle b il doit cesser
12e conclusions aux poncifs désormais
éculé sur le montage des murs et des
collectivités pour expliquer la soudaine
exécution des crédits devenus récemment
pointé le manque d'accompagnement et
d'ingéniérie de l'état je rappelle que
sur les gouvernements ne doivent bien
des années du nil les effectifs de la
dge m subi une véritable cure a besoin
de 356,1 gens à ménaka a senti
aujourd'hui par le sua a mené y avait à
peu près 130 130 tex est là comment en
2001 en 2012 mi 2012
je rappelle l'inefficience du tac
budgétaire des crédits de l but par la
tjo m 27 ans par la cour du kop que la
liste en vigie à gifi je rappelle un
autre que je rappe on pointe qu'avant
même d'accuser les collectivités pour
leurs prêts conduit disque a cité suite
l'état adulte est attelé à l'égard d'un
petit but l'outre-mer savez vous guérir
appelée i en matière de ses rêves à 736
millions d'euros
et pire ce montant augmente en guyane et
à mayotte
la promesse de l'état a consacré le
montant du produit de la vente des sea
dogs ou soutien de la politique logement
social outre-mer par un abondement de
l'alb il n'est pas tenu
cette affectation de montant total
comme ces petits véhicules cap millions
d'euos doivent être souples et en deux
fois ce maillot 110,7 millions d'euros
soit uniquement la moitié ont réellement
a bondi à une bévue pour les boursiers
18 cette poule dense sur les sentes soit
par un million de bipar se rappelle que
la valorisation des sites comme si 200
papillon et que la cdc appris du passé
des siècles tasse en sondant 62% de
cette valorisation globale troisième
conclusion le pilotage et la gestion des
crédits à pablo pino juin souffre d'une
grande opacité
les critères de ventilation géographique
d'autres répartition géographique
driving quelque peu objectif elle semble
se baserait sur de nombreux critères
difficilement évaluable par le parlement
et tend à reconduire deux camps dans ce
passé où à réagir dans l'urgence à des
mêmes chefs et un local denis contrebas
c'est très généraliste donc on peut pas
il a posé les critères objectifs
la chose exécution depuis 2015 des
motorisations à la joie est masqué par
des ajustements en chef transférables à
ce contenu
outre joseph les données tendent à
démontrer que lucas son organisme
je pèse mes mots sont réunis pour
aboutir en concentration des crédits de
nvi en travers cette crise chez terre en
a saisi qui d'ailleurs a dit olivia bien
avec verve et sainte est repris par un
député à l'assemblée nationale est ainsi
donc réaffecté à sa guise un crédit
le redéploiement interne du crazy horse
le geste en guérit pas la vie où elle
serait ainsi de manière centralisée aux
pattes et discrétionnaire la complexité
persistante et magloire cisco et des
valeurs autour ou en ce sens pour
quelques sous pulsions de la ville
laisse les dispositifs de
défiscalisation tombe à conclure à la
mise en oeuvre par l'état de logique
purement comptable d'économie donc face
à ce manque de volontarisme anita des
pouvoirs publics en faveur du logement
dans les outre-mers ce rapport plaide
une part pour la quantification et
meilleure mobilisation des financements
et d'autre part une véritable
territorialisation de la politique du
logement avec les priorités suivantes la
priorité des titans road racing
nativement les critiques la pile de cd
complexe et silencieusement les neymar
semaine satine assoupli les agréments
montre un terme aux soubresauts
législatif en matière de défisc 3 mettre
fin à l'opacité de gestion des finances
en public en instaurant des critères
objectifs transparents pour la
ventilation géographique et la
répartition interne un conte d'exercice
de la lbu 4 soldés mais reste appelée
guide l'état sous l'oeil nu à améliorer
significativement et améliorer
significativement le pilotage budgétaire
des très très grand qu'on sait les
moyens humains et financiers de la vigie
web et des services déconcentrés de
l'état qui doit moins deux personnes
pour le suivi tous 1,6 permettent une
meilleure représentation des outre-mer
par les act up nationale du logement et
uniformiser les dispositifs nationale
afin de mettre ses tripes et nation et
tenter autant cela est possible de
régler à l'amiable concluante du s agit
du show fait permettre l'intervention de
l'anah en outre mer en valeur et
propriétaires occupants et non plus
seulement des propriétaires bailleurs
n'augmenter le taux de subvention de
l'anah pour les travaux du propriétaire
bailleur à 50
aujourd'hui enfin moins de 35 pour ça et
réduit la durée d'un conventionnement
c'est c'est sincèrement pas normal que
l'ana ne soit pas plus active et enfin
huit instituts est une instance haddock
de conservation et de copines otages de
la politique territorialisée du logement
sous ce qui tue en hausse est de 10 h
saint laurent et les parabènes le
versement est remplaçant les locaux au
coeur du processus décisionnel et de
suivre il faut que ce soient
opérationnels et décisionnels
voilà ce que dit cette première partie
merci cher victor la parole anything
that
merci président mesdames messieurs 33000
c'est le nombre de familles en attente
d'un logement social rien que sur l'île
de la réunion
ce chiffre rappelé à l'occasion de la
visite de la ministre du logement
emmanuelle wargon dans l'océan indien à
l'ept sur l'ampleur de la crise du
logement dans nos territoires
aujourd'hui si 80% de la population des
drôme et éligibles au logement social
seuls 15 % y résident effectivement face
à cette situation les freins doivent
être levés pour soutenir la
réhabilitation et la construction de
logements sociaux
si beaucoup de mesures ont été prévues
par le plan de leur mise en oeuvre doit
aujourd'hui être accéléré je commencerai
par deux défis majeurs celui du foncier
aménagé et celui de l'adaptation des
normes ce et des chantiers sont capitaux
si l'on veut baisser les coûts des
opérations et construire davantage en
outre mer le foncier avait déjà fait
l'objet d'une étude triennale de la
délégation entre 2015 et 2017
les acteurs du logement auditionné lors
des tables rondes thématiques ont tous
insisté sur la nécessité de disposer
davantage de fonds s'est aménagé les
fonds régionaux d'aménagement foncier
urbain le frapru
doivent en principe permettre de
constituer des réserves foncières et de
réaliser des équipements d'aménagement
mais leur financement basé sur la lb et
sur des contributions des collectivités
locales et de l'union européenne restent
insuffisants pour répondre aux enjeux
la table ronde consacrée à la guyane est
également l'occasion de mesurer les
défis posés par l'opération d'intérêt
national women développer en guyane qui
devrait conduire à la réalisation de 23
mille logements d'ici 2027
si l'état s'est engagé à transférer
gratuitement des terrains
les sessions prennent du temps et sont
morcelées
par ailleurs à mayotte si le projet de
yens et a été acté les mesures
d'application n'ont toujours pas été
prises pour rendre le foncier plus
abordables les outils des boues réel
solidaires les brs permettent d'opérer
une dissociation entre le foncier le
bâti pour assurer aux plus modestes un
accès à la propriété et mériterait
d'être développée dans tous les
territoires
le chantier de l'adaptation des normes
doit également être menés à terme
l'inadaptation normative et dans l'un
des facteurs du renchérissement des
coûts
quatre ans après le rapport de la
délégation quelques progrès ont été
enregistrés notamment via la
constitution d'une commission locale de
normalisation à la réunion et de cellule
économique régionale de la construction
en guadeloupe et à la martinique
mais l'absence de ces structures dans
les territoires pourtant promise par le
plan 2 est aujourd'hui dommageable
surtout un travail important reste à
conduire avec la commission européenne
pour obtenir la dérogation du marquage
ce et e et la mise en place de manca rup
pour faciliter l'importation de produits
de l'environnement régional d outre mer
le travail mené par la nouvelle
calédonie avec le référentiel et au cnc
peut servir de modèle en la matière j'en
viens maintenant aux problématiques plus
spécifique de l'habitat indigne de la
mixité sociale et de la réhabilitation
ce sont là trois thèmes majeurs à
traiter si l'on revient sur un accès
pour toutes les populations un logement
décent et abordable l'habitat indigne
qui expose ses occupants à des risques
pour leur santé leur sécurité concerne
plus de 110 mille logements dans les
drom dans certaines comme la situation
particulièrement préoccupante comme à
saint martin ou moins de 40 % des
ménages disposent de l'eau chaude dans
leur logement alors qu'ils se
concentraient auparavant dans certaines
zones urbaines
le phénomène de l'habitat indigne est
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus diffus rendant
son identification et sans traitement
plus difficiles les opérations de
démolition se sont accélérées à mayotte
et en guyane depuis la loi élan de 2018
mais pour éviter de ne faire que
déplacer des bidonvilles ces opérations
doivent s'associer en amont et en aval
les populations pour identifier des
solutions pérennes de relogement les
actions d adil présente partout sauf à
mayotte et celle des associations comme
la fondation abbé-pierre uniquement
présente dans l'océan indien doivent
être encouragés surtout des solutions
innovantes doivent également être
recherchée les opération d'auto
construction et d'auto réhabilitation
peuvent apporter des réponses comme le
prouve le projet de résorption du talus
majicavo de koungou à mayotte
cependant elles sont encore peu utilisés
notamment du fait du manque de soutien
des assurances le défi sur nos
territoires est aussi d'assurer la
mixité sociale et de garantir des loyers
abordables pour les populations
il faut rappeler que la réunion et la
guadeloupe connaissent des loyers de
logements sociaux les plus élevés de
france proche des niveaux de l'île de
france
pour les ménages les plus modestes
existe dans les drom l'offre de
logements à loyer très sociaux llts bien
que le plan ne fixe un objectif de 30%
de lts dans le parc social d'ici 2022
les opérations de l lts restent
insuffisantes elles sont difficiles à
équilibrer et les garanties apportées
par les départs département sont trop
limitées il convient d'ouvrir d'autres
possibilités de cofinancement
le développement d'opérations de
construction de logements sociaux est
aujourd'hui freiné par les réticences de
certaines communes par les faiblesses du
secteur du btp et par les difficultés en
matière de formation la mixité sociale
doit être encouragée en intégrant
également une stratégie à destination de
l'offre intermédiaires et du parc privé
l'utile du prêt locatif social pls dont
les plafonds correspondent à ceux du
logement intermédiaire permettent de
participer à l'objectif de mixité
sociale
or le financement des logements pls est
limitée par la fixation d'un quota en
augmentation est aujourd'hui
indispensable
j'en termine avec les enjeux
d'amélioration de l'habitat et de la
réhabilitation
s'agissant de l'amélioration de
l'habitat privé
le compte n'y est pas les aides
nationales sont soit inexistantes soit
très faiblement déployées
ainsi l'aide habité facile qui permet
des travaux pour l'autonomie de la
personne n'est pas disponible dans les
drom
quant à m'en prive président qui finance
les travaux de rénovation énergétique
des logements seulement 700 dossiers ont
été engagés pour l'année 2020 dans
l'ensemble des drogues en outre
essentiellement concentrée à la réunion
les aides régionales divergent selon les
territoires et les acteurs déplorent un
éparpillement des dispositifs des
critères à rallonge et une faible
communication sur les mesures accessible
un guide spécifique sur ces aides
précisant les outils de financement
gagnerait à être mise en place
les autres maires et tout
particulièrement les antilles reste
marqué par l'ampleur du phénomène de la
vacance de logements qui concerne près
de 120 mille logements dans les drom le
travail d'identification des causes de
cette vacance 1 division habitat devenu
indigne difficultés passées entre
locataires et propriétaires est un
préalable nécessaire pour lutter contre
ce phénomène
il conviendrait de créer un opérateur
spécifique sur le modèle de celui
existant dans l'hexagone des solutions
innovantes comme les baux à
réhabilitation doivent également être
développés par ailleurs
alors qu'elle était prévue par la loi et
rome de 2017
la taxe sur les logements vacants n'est
toujours pas mises en oeuvre dans les
drom s'agissant du renouvellement urbain
six caisses ville ultra marines sont
éligibles au programme d'action coeur de
ville un important retard a été pris et
doit être aujourd'hui comblé pour lutter
contre l'étalement urbain et
l'artificialisation des sols les aides à
la démolition doivent être encouragées
enfin la question du retraitement de
l'amiante heurte à l'absence de filière
locale de désamiantage et rejoint la
problématique plus générale du recyclage
des matériaux de démolition donc
beaucoup reste donc à faire dans la
troisième et dernière partie du rappeur
j'aimerais vous exposer les raisons pour
lesquelles malgré toutes les difficultés
qui ont été rappelés par mes collègues
victorin lurel et micheline jacques
l'habitat dans les outre-mers peut être
un modèle d'adaptation et d'innovation
pour répondre aux nouveaux défis de la
politique du logement
et ceci pour trois raisons principales
d'abord les outre mer sont de véritables
laboratoires des évolutions des besoins
de logements et des modes d'habitat
ensuite ils sont déjà un terrain
d'expérimentation pour la destination de
dispositifs de procédures innovants
enfin les outre-mer ont un formidable
potentiel de systèmes constructifs
locaux adaptés aux nouveaux défis du
logement comme le réchauffement
climatique qui conviendraient surtout de
mieux promouvoir et mutualisés vous le
savez les outre-mers concentre sur des
espaces contraints l'ensemble des défis
qui impactent fortement la demande de
logements le premier défi majeur et dans
démographique le vieillissement
particulièrement accéléré aux antilles
nécessite un véritable plan stratégique
comme le préconise le rapport broussy
sur l'adaptation de l'habitat au
vieillissement
en 2050 la martinique sera le
département le plus vieux de france et
ce rapport parle même d'un scénario
catastrophe
ce plan devrait à mon sens être élargie
aux autres territoires également touchés
par la transition démographique comme la
réunion nos collègues viviane mallet et
nassimah dindar l'ont suffisamment
souligné et aux collectivités
d'outre-mer tout aussi concerné toutes
les solutions d'hébergement doivent
pouvoir être envisagée
du maintien à domicile au développement
d'établissements spécialisés en tenant
compte notamment des attitudes socio
culturel de chaque territoire où
accueillir les anciens séchoir est à la
fois une réalité une pratique mais aussi
un devoir
je suggère à cet égard deux pistes qui
ont été avancées lors des auditions et
tendre dans les drom le régime du
forfait autonomie pour les personnes
âgées afin de développer des résidences
autonomie et les conventions relatives à
l'accompagnement du vieillissement signé
entre les bailleurs sociaux et la cnav
le travail de prospective sur les
évolutions démographiques dans les
outre-mer ne peut être la transposition
des projections réalisées pour
l'hexagone
la cour des comptes notamment à
souligner combien lüthi othello qui
estime les besoins en logements en
france métropolitaine est inadaptée ne
serait ce qu'à cause des flux
migratoires ou de la part de l'habitat
informel fiabiliser l'évaluation des
besoins de logement dans les
départements et collectivités
d'outre-mer qui sont également en
déficit de données est un objectif qu'il
faut absolument atteindre pour aider à
la prise de décision par ailleurs on
oublie aussi trop souvent que certains
de ces territoires sont caractérisés par
des structures familiales plus d'enfants
par exemple et des modes de vie
notamment tourné vers l'extérieur qui
leur sont propres
cela a été rappelé avec force lors des
tables rondes sur la guyane mayotte et
lors des auditions sur la polynésie
française et la nouvelle calédonie il
faut donc à la fois en tenir compte et
intégrer les évolutions sociologiques
observé partout ailleurs comme
l'augmentation des familles
monoparentales ou la décohabitation des
jeunes ménages
le parcours résidentiel des familles
doit impliquer plus de modaris
modularité dans les habitations et
prendre davantage en compte la diversité
des publics que ce soit des personnes
handicapées des personnes âgées les
jeunes travailleurs étudiants familles
nombreuses
il convient donc de développer cette
date cette adaptabilité des logements en
associant davantage les acteurs du btp
et mobiliser les possibilités de la loi
élan pour développer l'offre de
logements évolutifs tout en associant
étroitement des architectes locaux comme
ils l'ont exprimé lors de la table ronde
sur l'habitat innovants après la
démographie l'exposition risques
naturels constituent un autre défi
majeur pour les outre-mer
la délégation a conduit entre 2017 et
2019 une étude en deux volets
portant notamment des propositions pour
améliorer la résistance du bâti reste
est malheureusement sans beaucoup de
suite en l'absence du projet de loi
annoncé cinq ans après le passage de
l'ouragan rma événement véritablement
traumatique
on constate combien les populations et
et résiliente dans trois domaines
au moins cette surexposition aux risques
donne aux outre-mer une avance certaine
et une réelle expertise le risque
cyclonique notamment aux antilles en
polynésie et à wallis et futuna et en
nouvelle calédonie le risque sismique
antillo mayotte et plus généralement le
réchauffement climatique
les solutions développées dans les
outre-mer devraient servir de source
d'inspiration des changes et de
référence je propose que l'ingénérie
terry technique territorial soit donc
étroitement associés aux politiques de
logement à ce titre je propose aussi de
promouvoir l' architecture bio petits
blocs bioclimatique pardon basé sur des
savoir faire traditionnels offrant des
solutions en particulier de ventilation
plus adaptée efficace et moins onéreuse
il faut privilégier les techniques
locales est déjà expérimenté plutôt que
de dire si la réglementation parra
cyclonique par exemple les architectes
auditionné ont rappelé qu'ils savaient
concilier les différents risques dans la
conception d'habitations mais aussi
proposer des solutions de refuge adapté
véritable laboratoire à ciel ouvert les
outre-mer sont des terres d'innovation
et d'expérimentation ce que l'on ne dit
jamais assez les grandes tendances de
l'habitat de demain ils sont déjà
perceptibles et identifie et identifié
densification des villes décarbonation
des procédés constructifs notamment
l'hybridité des systèmes constructifs
inertie des façades réduction des
énergies grises recours à la conception
bioclimatique est l'architecte de
l'architecturé vernaculaire augmentation
des matériaux de récupération ou issus
du recyclage traitement des espaces
publics extérieurs comme régulateur
thermique des résidus des réalisations
fondée sur une vision plus large des
enjeux de la construction incluant
désormais d'avantagé dimension
écologique social et curieux culturelles
sont déjà prometteuse éco quartier
habitat participatif ou collaboratif
programme au froment opérations
d'habitat renouveler dans les outre-mers
habitats légers ou times vous trouverez
dans le rapport les exemples qui nous
ont été données au fil des auditions
je crois qu'il faut encourager ces
pratiques innovantes intégrées dans le
paysage local et surtout en associant
les usagers il faut de manière
volontariste fléché encore davantage les
financements publics sur le
développement de ses nouveaux programmes
comme les écoquartiers on doit réfléchir
à certains assouplissement des règles
d'urbanisme notamment pour l'habitat
léger dans des zones circonscrites afin
d'offrir des solutions d'hébergement
plus rapide et moins cher pour soutenir
l'innovation il convient aussi de
simplifier les processus de validation
des innovations pour les rendre plus
accessibles aux entreprises ultramarines
qui sont de taille réduite et surtout
comme la sujet suggéré le cdc habitat
réussir à bâtir une filière de recherche
et développement sur l'habitat innovant
avec de grands organismes nationaux avec
des financements européens et en prenant
appui sur une expertise d outre-mer je
rappelle qu'il existe six universités
ultramarines l'université des antilles
et de guyane de la réunion de mayotte de
la nouvelle calédonie et de polynésie
française et avec un total de 33 mille
étudiants dont 16% de niveau master qui
devrait être plus fortement impliqué le
chantier test sera bien entendu celui de
la performance énergétique des bâtiments
avec l'actualisation en cours de la
réglementation spécifique thermique
acoustique aération mise en place en
2016 pour les dom et l'introduction
demain de la réglementation
environnementale 2020 compte tenu des
difficultés de toutes sortes qui ont été
pointés sur l'évaluation même de cette
performance il convient sans doute de
mettre en place une réglementation
thermique pour les drom adaptés à chaque
bassins océaniques
cela a été souligné également il
faudrait déjà commencer par facilité
l'accès aux dispositifs d'amélioration
énergétique existant dans l'hexagone
comme ma prime rénove dont la diffusion
est encore dérisoires en outre-mer enfin
pour apporter les solutions pérennes il
faut promouvoir les systèmes
constructifs locaux et mutualiser
davantage les bonnes pratiques
chaque territoire ultramarin dispose de
savoir faire traditionnels qu'il
faudrait non seulement sauvegarder mais
aussi valoriser à cet égard un effort
par
culié doit être déployée de manière
urgente avec l'aide des organisations
professionnelles en faveur de la
formation d'artisans spécialisés dans
une utilisation de matériaux locaux bio
sourcés la priorité est donc de soutenir
les filières locales intégrant les
matériaux biosourcés la renaissance de
la filière de la brique de terre par
exemple à mayotte doit ainsi être
soutenu et en étendue à d'autres
expérimentations il convient
d'encourager partout dans les outre-mers
la constitution de filières associant
architectes bureaux d'études entreprises
et donneurs d'ordre autour de ces
matériaux les plates formes généreuses
de rénovation notamment doivent pouvoir
accompagner et conseiller les porteurs
de projets les auditions ont montré
qu'il existe des potentialités
multipliés aux richesses naturelles des
outre-mer peint des caraïbes en bout
bagasse vétiver fall catamaran angélique
waka pouquoi pas et j'en passe on peut
lors de la construction d'équipements
publics recourir davantage aux matériaux
locaux
à titre d'exemple l'écomusée de moorea
en polynésie française que le président
de la république visitera fin juillet a
été conçu pour mettre en avant le bois
et le style local
partout une solution alternative d
existe il faut s'efforcer de substituer
au béton des matériaux locaux beaucoup
plus efficace compte tenu des conditions
climatiques
que ce soit sur l'humidité où la
sérénité de l'air limiter les
importations de ciment et intégrer cet
objectif dans la conception du bâtiment
entraînerait selon les acteurs du
logement auditionné une baisse
substantielle des coûts de construction
dans cette perspective au fil des
auditions de nombreuses propositions ont
été émises comme développer au niveau
régional des pôles d expertise ou
dynamiser les échanges sur l'habitat de
tels échanges existent entre saint
pierre et miquelon et les quais neda
bien qu'entre bien qu entravée par la
problématique des normes européennes et
mériterait d'être davantage développée
pour la réunion et mayotte avec
madagascar et l'afrique du sud et
notamment pour les antilles avec le
brésil et les états unis
l'habitat constitue indéniablement un
levier de développement pour la comédie
coopération régionale c'est le pari fait
par la nouvelle calédonie par exemple
avec le projet d'habitat océaniens pour
les états du pacifique comme fidji one
way to en conclusion
pour mutualiser toutes ces réflexions je
crois qu'il est temps et qu'il est
nécessaire d'organiser dès que possible
des assises dédié à la construction en
outre-mer le plum 2 s'achevant
théoriquement en 2022
l'état serait bien avisé d'y songer dès
à présent et d'aller y puiser les
facteurs du rééquilibrage
l'idée a fait l'unanimité tant auprès
des organismes nationaux que des
responsables locaux
ces assises qui réunir l ensemble des
acteurs du secteur du logement outre-mer
serait à la fois la vitrine et la
plateforme des modes d'habiter dans les
outre-mers la délégation aux outremers
pourrait me semble-t-il joué un rôle
moteur dans le lancement de ce projet
vous merci merci cher cher rapporteur
ces présentations ayant été effectués le
propose maintenant si vous le voulez
d'engager la phase d' échanges avec les
journalistes qui nous font le plaisir
d'être présent parmi nous et ceux qui
sont en distance yale que je ne vois pas
à l'écran mais on indiquera le cas
échéant ceux qui voudront prendre la
parole et je vous la scène de bien
volontiers maintenant pour vous posez
vos questions aux rapporteurs sur ce
rapport d'information
si vous pouvez vous présenter et mettre
le micro quand vous prenez la parole
juste pour l'enregistrement ce sera plus
simple
oui bonjour une alternative journal chez
avait fait un faux j'ai deux questions
d'abord j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment
par rapport aux pommes de d'un point de
vue global c'est vrai que quand on est
passé aux plumes de on disait que celui
ci serait beaucoup plus de
territorialiser qui prenait compte des
échecs et du club 1
pour vous qu'est-ce qui va pas en fait
avec ce plan m 2 finalement
effectivement le plan 2 il est beaucoup
plus payant otero territorialisée pardon
cependant il ya un certain nombre de
zones d'opacité au niveau des différents
territoires il n'est pas assez défini on
ne trouve quasiment nulle part pour
avoir accès il a fallu aller vers la des
racks la direction enfin deux des
outre-mer et est en fait les îles la
mise en oeuvre n'est pas efficace dans
les départements d'outre-mer donc il
conviendrait justement de le revoir et
de pouvoir intégrer
chaque composante du plan puisqu'ils
restent vagues par exemple si vous
regardez celui de la réunion la
déclinaison au niveau de mayotte c'est
quelque chose de difficile n'y a pas
d'objectif vraiment précis
et je rajouterais juste pour compléter
ce que vient de dire machine jacques ces
photons sur le plot main et a eu un
bilan qu'on a plus considérés comme
largement suffisant puisque l'objectif
de 10 mille logements n'a jamais été
atteint autant sur le plan m 2
aujourd'hui on n'a aucune données
détaillées d'exécution diplôme alors
qu'on est à mi parcours ce qui quand
même un indicateur important il ya bien
une communication qui a eu lieu je crois
en 2020 avec une annonce de 8000
logements d'ailleurs le ministère de
l'outre-mer a communiqué il ya quasiment
concomitante avec la présentation notre
apport hier en un an sont la
construction de 6000 logements mais
c'est vrai qu'en termes d'exécution
c'est un des points soulevés dans le
rapport au delà des logements qui
peuvent être financées il est
fondamental qu'on puisse également
disposer des chiffres des logements dont
la construction est lancée et ceux qui
peuvent être livrés parce que pour nos
concitoyens c'est quand même c'est quand
même essentiel de savoir avec
concrètement ce qui vit ce qui va être
livrés ou ce qui est en cours et pas
forcément seulement ce qui est financée
donc on n'a pas aujourd'hui des éléments
et micheline l'a rappelé qu'ils nous
permettent de dire que on est à mi
parcours et qu'on va vers des horizons
un peu plus positif bien au contraire on
est relativement pessimiste aujourd'hui
sur l'état de réalisation et on le dit
de manière très objective n'y a pas de
pas de calcul politique derrière
aujourd'hui on ne dispose pas de ces
éléments qui seraient de nature à nous
rassurer et rassurer aussi nos
compatriotes et juste pour ma deuxième
question est ce que vous diriez que
l'ana c'est un peu là le trou dans la
raquette en matière de politique du
logement d'outre-mer que ce soit sur la
vie de la lutte contre l'habitat indigne
ou la rénovation du parc existant
pendant la problématique que l'on trouve
au niveau des propriétaires occupants il
ya énormément les problèmes de l'auto
construction et de l'auto réhabilitation
pose un souci au niveau assurantiel nous
avons des assurances qui refusent bien
que ces s'est auto construction soit
encadrée par des organismes et des
associations qui sont des professionnels
de l'habitat donc par conséquent comme
les assurances refusent de couvrir ces
logements dans les populations ne sont
pas ne se dirige pas vers ce type de de
l'organisation pour pouvoir se loger
maurice et canal 10 coadout côtés martin
ktv guyane à travers cette étude ont été
bien sûr en avant la carence de l'état
travers les différents plans qui est la
place des collectivités souple coelho
martin guyonnet ce qu' elle peut jouer
un rôle plus important
justement c'est le gros défaut de 2,7 de
ces plans de logements c'est que les
collectivités ne sont pas assez
impliqués et nous ce que nous
préconisons dans le rapport justement ce
serait de territorialiser ces schémas en
développant notamment des plans locaux
d'urbanisme handident aussi les
collectivités parce qu'elles veulent
bien s'y mettre mais malheureusement
elle ne dispose pas d'assez d'ingénierie
pour pouvoir arriver à construire de
véritables documents d'urbanisme nous
avons énormément de collectivités qui
sont toujours sous le statut du
règlement
national d'urbanisme et ça n'aide pas
les collectivités à mettre en place des
règles vraiment spécifique
je me permets kessy way shop a pas
d'excusé moyenne oui je me permets
simplement de donner la parole à victor
ainsi s'il souhaite je sais pas si on va
parler mais je n'ai rien à part dieu
j'ai pas peur du la nature des questions
et souhaitons pas plus pour voir ça
marche vraiment
bon je vous la donne au moins une
importante quitté poser c'est comment on
quelle peut être la place des
collectivités dont processus qui est
décrit au travers du rapport
alors non on a parlé de kevin
organisation plus est la plus
approfondie
on n'a pas employé le mot de
décentralisation de la politique du
logement
parce que en fait il faut être conscient
que la politique du logement est une
politique d'état les petits descendance
et du central du sommet que ça descend
vers le bas on pourrait dire bon donc
aujourd'hui c'est l'état qui a tout en
mai les prix réels et des cibles et
viale le bureau des agréments de l'été
les premières élections et qui a tout on
ne vient marginalement les collectivités
et peut-être demain un peu si ce
notamment dans l'amélioration de
l'habitat
c'est devenu une question très politique
voire politicienne le cacher il y as ton
klein moyen terme à trouver ce que nous
avons trouvé deux dits qu'il faut une et
stoch haddock de condamnations qu'ils
soient opérationnels qu'il soit
décisionnel et qu'ils remettent les ai
vus au coeur du système
voilà donc c'est un moyen terme qui est
réaliste qui devrait marcher faut-il
avant qui viennent volonté politique
affirmée alors que je dis c'est pour die
drôme
puisque les statuts de la polynésie et
de la nouvelle calédonie y compris
peut-être à saint pierre et miquelon il
est peut-être plus grande marge de
manoeuvre dans la conduite et le
pilotage de la politique de logement
n'ont pas découvert les manifestement tu
tout cas en regardant le match de
contrôle et d'évaluation
il faut peut-être au plus près à ce
qu'ils visent idéalités donné plus de
pouvoir aux collectivités de contrôle
mais aussi conquois de financement je
pense que l'exemple l'état dans son
assistance et les gilles viry que l'on
veut financer
il n'y a pas d'intention bannissement
sommes un territoire y en avait une
en guadeloupe qui a disparu pour faire
un plus qu'il ya encore de quoi le
footsie commune chez moi qui n'ont pas
de plus j'ai qui sont souvent rnu l'aï
l'avs il ya des petites choses
qu'est ce qui est un peu irritant et je
finis l'ins 8 ans et de voir en ville ça
au quotidien et vous entendez une
communication look communications entre
est très apprécié a titré nous décrit je
veux faire plus tard et en même temps
stigmatisant pour les collectivités
parce qu'elle n'aurait pas d'une grille
elle fut vérifie s'il touche que c'est
une collectivité d'une commune ou
peut-être à mettre les pieds bien c'est
de voir avec un bailleur commentaires de
trouver du foncier foncia ménagez vous
avez des eaux puis hier il faut
l'écouter roulement pour faire
l'acquisition est ensuite aménagé tout
cela mérite d'être revu merci victorin
vous vouliez poser une autre question en
espérant guidera également plus merci
alors donc ici vous échappe outre-mer la
première france télévisions en fait
en vous écoutant on entend une
succession de plans en additionnant un
peu de mesure qui s'associent qui vont
ensemble ou presque mais on voit
toujours les mêmes difficultés outre mer
parce que je me demande puisqu'on parle
d' impliquer les collectivités danse
dans ce travail donc tout à l'heure
monsieur lurel parler de cette
commission ad-hoc cette instance ado qui
pourrait être mise en place
est-ce que déjà il faudrait pas un peu
déblayé tout le système du logement
outre-mer faire en sorte que les choses
soient peut être clarifiées parce que à
cette responsabilité en fait des
collectivités toujours invoquer je pense
notamment la gueule parce que j étais où
on disait voilà on vous donne des fonds
mais vous ne parvenez pas à mettre en
place ce qu'il faut pour pouvoir les
déployer quel que soit d'ailleurs les
dossiers concernés est ce que finalement
c'est pas d'autre question qu'il
faudrait poser devant cette fois ci le
gouvernement disant ok en fait les
statuts doivent être revus afin que les
territoires est plus d'impact en tout
cas plusieurs responsabilités sur
certains sujets notamment le logement
parce que finalement enfin moi ce que
j'entends c'est qu'on parle là dedans on
parle de statut des territoires
ils entrent pas est ce que vous avez
entendu huit ans simplement juste un
exemple et en temps quand on évoque par
exemple le fait de travailler avec les
territoires locaux enfin les territoires
dans la zone le brésil etc sont des
choses qui sont souvent invoqué
notamment en guyane pour les goudrons
travail avec le suriname et puis ce sont
des questions qui ne fonctionne pas
notamment à cause des normes européennes
donc en fait voilà c'est toujours un peu
le serpent qui se mord est que quel que
soit le domaine
mon résumé en synthèse est forcément
évident et française et je pense qu'on
n'hésitez pas à me reprendre cas échéant
et ces gens réalisent de france ont été
les premières suggéré que ces questions
qui sont évoqués on peuvent renvoyer à
des questions statutaires ultramarines
même si vous avez pris soin victorin
d'évoquer la territorialisation est pas
la décentralisation ce qui est un
élément déjà de réponse par rapport à la
question que madame à poser est est ce
que finalement il faudrait pas
dépoussiérés nettoyer et déblayer
l'existant en matière de logement en
outre-mer pour éviter de retomber dans
les travers que qui sont décrits et
auquel on nous essayons d'apporter une
réponse dans le dans le rapport et on
dans la synthèse dans un des voix n'a
pas besoin de changement at 8 r
sincèrement ça dépend de la volonté
politique le gouvernement et du
parlement de décentraliser on note la
décentralisation sans pour autant
changer le sketch en échange est
l'organisation la donne et des
compétences et ont inversé la fédé
transfert de financement on n'a pas
besoin de fabien sune sûr de maîtriser
totalement l'état a du mal à se séparer
de chagrin et lyon avoir appelé vous le
combat qu'il a fallu pour que le médecin
d outre-mer en soit chargée
c'est le ministère du logement
d'ailleurs on voit que l'essentiel
vertes' les qualifications coordonnées
bâtir sans vouloir rester au ministère
du logement
on n'a pas besoin de changement
statutaire pensa alors évidemment si
dans le débat actuel en juillet la loi
demandant si ne c'est pas pour 1 heure
sur une loi organique sur la fusion de
l'article 73 74
cela fera nécessairement savary de
belles choses avec une gradation un
phasage en urbanisme et en logement et
ses parents tout à fait et pleinement
opérationnelle
bon mais je le dis que dans le cadre
actuel l'état que se rapprocher plus des
territoires associés davantage et du
contrôle et que tu aimes s'ils me font
rares en plus mais on n'a pas besoin
d'agir vaste chantier près à la mairie
serait que changera de statut
on peut faire ça
voilà donc c'est en fait cette façon
jacobine de santé oms et mon argent je
vois le gérer une crue près ensuite on a
encore du pain éventuellement coupable
bon et puis j'ai la chance que contient
ce petit comme je le dis depuis je le
nombre d'années que je suis en politique
simplement petite question par
concernant les retards en fait du plan
du plm 2 il me semble selon certains
communiqués qu'on a reçue du
gouvernement qu'ils invoquent un peu
aussi la crise qu vide
voilà pour expliquer que certaines
choses et pris du retard est ce que
quelque chose qui a pu être vérifiée
travail de traduction vous fait à
nouveau leur eu des victoires sur le sol
sur le pommeau de notamment à sa tante
de communication qui sont assorties du
comité de suivi l'homme de l'est laisse
penser qu'effectivement la crise qu vide
est sans doute venu vraisemblablement
ralentir ce que nous trouvions déjà très
lent ralentir l'exécution du plan est ce
que ces éléments ont été également
évoqués lors des auditions que vous avez
pu mener
oui on a entendu ça et c'est bien dans
le rapport à la première partie le
premier confinement pour être clair
raconté je crois dit-il 7 mars 2002 mais
il ya eu des arrêts de chantier bon
c'est d'ailleurs l'un des prétextes et
par le gouvernement pour dire s'il y a
du retard dans la réunion du comité de
pilotage s'est enquis de diablo cody
comprenant une année c'était en mars
2009 et en mars 2021 ce n'a pas donné
grand chose
ce communiqué de presse donc
manifestement là les tables en bois rond
comme le digital poivrons prendre 1 6
turbo à conforter les effectifs jeunes à
la vie j boem non pas deux personnes il
faut des experts il faut mieux
ordination avec les directions de jeu
tunisair du logement et je revienne
la première question posée jeu non
magique
dans l'état actuel il est un peu perdu
l'état publicité se cachant derrière la
lolf vous dire c'est conforme à la loi
organique relative aux finances
publiques parce que l'on constante les
crédits en fin d'année aux frais des
mots déploiement à l'insu de tous à tous
les critères comme on dit en
mathématiques
personne ne plus aimer ça manifestement
là il ya une volonté qui est en fait une
culture kid il a installé dans les
esprits depuis longtemps que son droit
cette centralisation parisienne c'est
l'argent des contribuables sa voiture
est à paris ça a été la même chose pour
que la tva npr polar centralisées à
paris
quand vous voulez la dépense et même
chose pour la batte pas fiscale sur le
revenu
bon on le centralisateur et quand vous
voulez indisposées alors d'un pistolet
de manière autonome et libre
et bien maintenant il faut nous demander
des subventions au ministère celle ci
était librement employés par les
entreprises aujourd'hui se demander
c'est une recentralisation a un qui
serait à l'insu de tous et donc la
politique du logement souffre de ça
depuis longtemps
je pense que plus de liberté donnée
après panier de contrôler plus de 2 des
traits à la promo de leur eau pour bien
fixer les objectifs en assurer le suivi
serait nécessaire et peut-être à qu'on
dit des montants correspondant aux
besoins et non pas des actes être moi
même ministre hâtif au dernier moment il
faut purger le permis de construire
au dernier moment il faut envoyer un
architecte conseil correspond pas du
tout à ce faire nous à notre dos rond
mais à m
comme le cadre de pensée manifestement
là il y à une évolution qu elle qu'il
faudra peut-être un cause ne laissera
pas contribuer à celle espère à changer
un peu les esprits et espérons le 2 mai
les comportements exactions
je disais que l'on sera pas vous parler
de 120 mille logements vacants et
chiffre très important que les mesures
qu'il faudrait prendre on jeudi une
mesure urgent pour faire face à ce
phénomène
alors comme nous l'avons préconisé la
taxe sur les logements vacants seraient
peut-être un levier pour permettre de
d'encourager les propriétaires de
logements vacants de pouvoir les faire
accéder les louer cependant il faut
faire aussi la part des choses vous avez
des logements vacants qui se sent qu'ils
sont issus de succession donc il ya de
gros problèmes d'indivision successorale
la loi letchimy a permis d'avancer un
petit peu mais malheureusement elle elle
ne va pas et là certaines limites et ses
logements à force de ne pas être
utilisés ils se dégradent rapidement
donc on arrive aussi à des logements qui
devienne indigne et l'objectif c'est
d'éviter cette dégradation du logement
en essayant d'encourager les gens
pouvoir louer leur logement ils les
entretenir
tant que vous dites que la lolette
chimie a touché ses limites dans ce
domaine elle a permis de régler un
certain nombre de choses mais elle a
quand même certaines ya certaines
limites puisqu'il faudrait l'étendre à
des successions qui sont beaucoup plus
récentes que des successions de 10 ans
excusez moi j'y reviens parce que c'est
une question qui maintient à l'or il ya
un point simplement qui m'interpelle il
me semble que vous l'aviez évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est celui d'utiliser aient les
ressources locales enfin j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure voilà le les ressources
locales des territoires avoisinants le
brésil sur etam le canada etc
ça suppose quand même un certain nombre
de changements législatifs on parle de
quelque chose où il faut vraiment adapté
nous on est toujours en tout cas je dis
nous ce que l'outre-mer forcément et que
j'étais en guyane mais on était
systématiquement confrontés à des
problématiques de type voilà les normes
européennes ne correspondent pas à telle
ou telle matière première donc comment
faire pour effectivement entrer dans ce
type de fonctionnement c'est la parole à
guillaume sur le volet prospectives oui
merci
c'est sûr que c'est quelque chose qu'on
a bien bien vu des différentes auditions
sur vous et parlez du du canada afin de
l'utilisation du bois
que ce soit en guyane aussi avec de la
même manière l'utilisation d'autres
matériaux en tout cas sur l'autre
continent et c'est vrai qu'avec des
réglementations et avec des normes qui
sont énormes européenne est donc
clairement qui pose une vraie
problématique qu à espérer que si on
veut se recentrer si on veut réfléchir
sur l'utilisation de matériaux locaux
mais du coup locaux sans ce ne sont plus
larges coin est passé est passé les
frontières et utiliser des matériaux
juste chercher chez les voisins les plus
proches
c'est sûr que ça demande à ce que l'on
puisse réfléchir à 7 à cette
harmonisation en tout cas cette
correspondance des normes parce qu'on
s'aperçoit l'exemple du du bois canadien
président artano pour en parler est un
exemple et un exemple assez assez
parlants quoi parce que c'est c'est vrai
qu'il faudrait pas grand chose pour
pouvoir harmoniser donc là c'est sûr
qu'il ya un travail normatif à faire ce
qui peut être intéressant c'est de
s'appuyer aussi on j'ai parlé de la
question de la réglementation thermique
qui du coup pareil a eu toute une
réflexion mais qui n'est pas du tout
adapté sur sur les territoires
ultramarins et que le fait qu'il ya un
travail là dessus aussi pour se dire
comment comment on peut adapter
justement et avoir peut-être d une
réglementation thermique pour le coup
justement territorialisée quoi adapter
ce suspect yvan les suivants les
territoires on pourrait aussi avoir
cette réflexion et c'est ce qui est
d'ailleurs une de nos propositions sur
la question de l'harmonisation en tout
cas de la correspondance des différentes
normes quoi qui paraît indispensable si
justement on veut utiliser on veut
utiliser les matériaux qui sont de
proximité sûr sûr sûr l'énorme juste
pour rappeler de manière générale il ya
quand même une force d'inertie à c'est
assez invraisemblable puisque le la
délégation sénatoriale du sénat a fait
un rapport sur l'évolution des normes en
2015 avec un certain nombre de
propositions concrètes
justement ce que vient de rappeler
président retard sur l'harmonisation des
normes en utilisant des matériaux qui se
croient pas des matériaux c'est eux mais
qu'ils pourraient trouver une
équivalence soit en qualité énergétique
soit en qualité structurelle et on voit
bien qu'il ya de la résistance au niveau
national mais je sais et nous avons
entendu lors de nos tables rondes qu'un
certain nombre de collectivités
travaillent justement à une
harmonisation et je pense que ces
exemples la veuve ont inspiré d'autres y
compris au niveau central pour qu'il ya
un véritable travail qui a été fait le
sait qu'il ya eu récemment une réunion
de travail au ministre à l'outre-mer sur
la loi 3ds qui va arriver en discussion
au sénat
l'évolution des normes restent un sujet
à part entière mais qui est un sujet
également européen mais je pense que si
déjà au niveau français il avait une
impulsion qui pouvait être donnée pour
tenir compte de ces réalités
ultramarines dont chacun de nos bassins
je pense que déjà le signal serait un
signal fort avec la valorisation de ce
qu'a rappelé le président gontard des
constructions locales à des processus
des cursus de formation nos artisans sur
nos territoires avec les matériaux de
nos territoires ou des matériaux de
proximité je pense que là on parle même
de mise en place d'une filière complète
c'est une approche peut-être qui
n'a pas encore eu lieu jusqu'ici et qui
en tout cas le mérite vraisemblablement
d'apporter des éléments de réponse qui
nous paraissent aller dans le bon sens
oui a ajouté un point sur cette question
dès des normes c'est vrai que c'est
c'est un problème justement sur sur les
territoires d'outre-mer et le fait que
ben y'a pas de correspondance avec les
normes françaises ou européennes
mais on retrouve la même problématique
même g en métropole quand on quand on
réfléchit sur des nouveaux matériaux
cancon sont pas forcément mais dès qu'on
essaie justement de parler m matériaux
biosourcés que ce soit construction en
paille construction en changeant fin
surtout ces matériaux qui sont là où on
a la même problématique d'évolution des
normes parce qu'en fait pour faire
labelliser ou avoir une norme sur tel ou
tel produit c'est quelque chose qui
coûte très cher et donc qui est
accessible que par des groupes très
important et donc pas du tout adapté en
fait à au développement de filières très
local quoi donc c'est même une réflexion
c'est pour ça que que dans le rapport on
a pu aussi beaucoup pour dire que le
territoire du peuple vraiment être un
laboratoire de réflexion justement sur
comment relocaliser les matériaux parce
que c'est des réflexions qu'on retrouve
de toute façon à l'échelle du pays quoi
je souhaiterais mettre en avant
l'expérience de la nouvelle calédonie
qui a été précurseur dans ce domaine
puisqu'elle s'est saisi du sujet suite
au rapport qui au premier rapport qui a
été produit et il ont mis en place en
référentiel de compétences de la
nouvelle calédonie concernant en matière
de logements neufs qui s'éteint cela
rassemble tous les professionnels
divisés sur trois actes dont galax
assurantielle en imposant une assurance
avec un axe de formation et un axe
d'agrément de des matériaux dont il ya
des expériences qui sont menées et en
collaboration aussi avec des territoires
proches de manière à trouver comme
disait le président tanoh trouver des
équivalences et a proposé à l'union
européenne des équivalences en matière
normatif l'objectif n'étant pas de
produits à des bâtiments qui serait
moins moins solides ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas le cas mais au conte
r avec cette même solidité se baser
aussi sur le local puisque nous avons
aussi partout dans nos territoires des
bâtiments qui ont été mis à rude épreuve
avec les différents phénomènes notamment
cyclonique et qui ont montré leur
solidité
donc l'objectif c'est vraiment d'y
arriver est de pouvoir convaincre
l'union européenne que idée
d'équivalence peuvent être possibles et
parallèlement ça limiterait les coûts et
limitera aussi l'empreinte carbone que
de faire venir du milieu des matériaux
de l'europe alors que nous avons à
proximité et développer des structures
locales de l'économie locale j'y courage
c'est que je suis intimement convaincu
que par le biais de du logement du
logement en général du logement social
nous pouvons aussi avoir des leviers
pour développer un pan de l'économie
ultramarine
si si absolument victoire rapproche ont
également dû me trop d'accord mais non
j'aimerais marquer un fichier en tout
cas le soutien à ce que mes deux
collègues rapportent rien te dis et moi
je pense que c'est vrai si vous êtes une
de la nouvelle calédonie du bras de fer
cette aventure
cependant c'est parfaitement
transposable dans nos territoires sans
pour autant attendre les calendes
grecques ou ultra marines aux avancées
sur le sujet c'est un problème de
volonté politique
lorsque personnellement avec ajouté
j'avais décidé de s'attaquer au problème
de la réglementation thermique dans la
sphère habilitation la fais ça nous a
coûté c'est vrai dans l'infernale donc
non pas une mais deux albums on n'a
qu'une hâte et j en dessous elle devrait
se terminer
même chose pour la formation je dis pas
que c'est le meilleur véhicule la
visitation
parce qu'ils l'ont et ça coûte cher mais
c'est une volonté politique et au
gouvernement et au parlement donc nos
parlementaires a montré qu'ils pressent
de cet entraînement lutte contre une
vulture à gré à l'époque on va dire
qu'on va dépasser les passionnés pape n
6 mondial sismique
bon c'était la croix et la bannière donc
il faut assouplir
il faut alléger aujourd'hui on peut
chercher querelle à tétouan la gauche
l'argent qu'ils ont été attaqués
suffisant à simplifier et à prôner sait
aussi qu'en faire confiance à m o au
plus près des gens en solidarité
les pouvoirs de décision sur skype app
voilà merci merci victor ans en j'ai une
question que deux en l'occurrence de
madame valérie reliques et qui est
rédactrice en chef d'actualité habitat
donc je la livre au rapporteur
la première avait vous estimez le besoin
en logements sociaux outre-mer combien
ou et pour qui puis pensez vous que les
organismes hlm sont assez solides
financièrement pour y répondre
victorin je pense que c'est pour vous
oui peut on construire c'est ça convient
d'abord oui combien de logements sociaux
qu'elle ait besoin en logements sociaux
aujourd'hui où je ne les ai pas en tête
mais c'est pas le dollar à bord il faut
qu'on suit tout simplement en guyane et
à mayotte par yann moix sa démographie
que la très forte mais il faut
construire partout et il faut surtout
compte tenu des contraintes foncières et
notamment du foncier aménagé il faut
qu'un la reconquête du centre-ville et
décembre vous il faut réhabiliter tout
dans les territoires
lorsqu'on avait dit à l'époque il
fallait dix mille de gens ne vous
réhabilité dans le premier comme bon
c'était quantitatif n'a pas hésité pas à
succès on ajoutait cinq points devant
aussi dans l'écho faisait 15 me
cautionnement et nous et on est à peine
à une île on en est très loin
donc il faut construire partout sur le
territoire
selon les remonter c'est ça votre
réalisation et le comité adam ont
heureusement été fixé et ne pas laisser
à la b0 aime à faire des oies déploiera
un petit questionnaire il faut construit
pas tout il faut réhabiliter partout il
faut faire accéder à la propriété
partout dans les outre-mer je ne prends
ton de la deuxième l'aviation est ce que
les les les hlm sont financièrement
suffisamment solides pour y répondre
alors les noms des meilleurs sociaux
c'est une question de petite taille et à
ses nombreux chez moi trop nombreux me
dit ont aidé à la région qui a une
restructuration opérée
mais j'avoue que moi j'ai une inquiétude
précisément parce que des mauvaises
gestions parce qu'il ya eu des scandales
parce qu'il ya tout ça on a voulu
regrouper la loi il a deux lapins adopté
sanchez deuxième chose ça c'est fait
autrement dans les outre-mer c'est
l'achat d'une seat sommes alors il ya là
un vrai problème et j'ai entendu ça dans
ce cas pas une politique très sympa de
campagne départemental et régional de
cire à waimes et on a perdu la liberté
de piloter notre politique de logement
parce que c'est des ses habitats à une
action de 8,6 d'hommes pour moi il donc
fait du bon boulot
ils ont assaini ils ont rétabli ils ont
lancé une politique qu'il faut évaluer
et peut-être aussi contrôler ou en tout
cas être mieux associés ces quarante
mille vefa ils ont retenu six mille
logements construite mais c'est très
bien mais le problème c'est qu'on avait
cédé ses fils et ses habitats la banque
des territoires lens que si d'ici
habitat c'est un projet bon j'imagine
qu'ils ne contenaient de sa surface
financière et de ses liens avec la cdc
n'a aucun problème de financement pour
la bande de territoire
est-ce que les autres meilleurs sociaux
auront la même audience le même accès au
crédit et la même rapidité pour
reconstruire aujourd'hui ses initiales
et le référent prééminent dans les
autres mers et les le contrôle que pour
les élus pour les populations
pour les associations de résidents il ya
là une question qu'il faut inscrire 11
est constamment pour que en transparence
la démocratie
eh bien nous soyons associés et que les
autres bailleurs sociaux soient
financiers comme il convient c'est
pourquoi j'ai posé la question d'une
action logement lorsque sa fin après ils
ne sont pas exonérés de la tfpb quand
c'est une banque des territoires il ya
quelques petites machines
symétrie davantage qu'il faut auquel il
faut rester attentif
voilà oui il faut qu'on revoie et c'est
ce qu'on dit dans le rapport
ce cocktail à cjms ce que font nos
dépens pourquoi l'acheter se retirer
petit à petit après avoir vendu cantine
6 tonnes en faire la demande de l'état
il ya là manifestement un problème de
suivi du financement et six autres de la
solidité financière des bailleurs
sociaux
merci victorin je ne vois pas d'autres
questions c'était le corps je propose de
claude y aurait un autre conférence de
presse en tout quoi vous remercier pour
ceux des journalistes qu'ils ont fait le
plaisir de nous rejoindre et ceux qui
ont pu participer également distance
merci victorin malgré les ennuis
techniques d'avoir pu contribuer
évidemment la restitution de ce rapport
et sa conférence de presse
et je lève cette séance merci à vous
toutes et vous tous merci victorin à
très bientôt
[Musique]